foreign
you know basically if you optimize for
fertility you're optimizing for Vitality
so there again I want to just thank you
because that's an extremely efficient
but also extremely Sage way to think
about optimizing for Vitality so it's
not just about wanting to have kids it's
about maintaining all your biological
systems at their right tuning super
helpful proxy super helpful what in this
case what do you mean by vitality
waking up feeling
well enough to want to begin your day
with enough energy to complete your day
and
to be able to have
to move back and forth along the
Continuum of
driven and relaxed eliminating
relationships to others as a component
for the moment of course it is a
component setting that aside rather
what I just described it to me is the
definition of mental health the ability
to lean into effort but also to relax
and restore your system
and to feel good about what you're doing
and being able to move from driven to
reflective when these kinds of things
so many people we know don't want to
give a geographical they all left the
bay area anyway there I just said it was
a bear you know the successful but
miserable we knew a lot of those or
people that can't seem to get enough
energy to focus and get get down a path
of a Pursuit so you want both that's
Vitality to me and this is getting kind
of Eastern philosophy which is more your
domain than mine and I'm always eager to
learn here but you know when you think
about Chi or kind of dopamine or Life
Energy the desire to create things in
the world
including Offspring but just to birth
ideas birth businesses birth
relationships Earth podcasts whatever it
is is is essentially from the same place
of having some idea in mind and trying
to construct that overcoming fear your
Notions of fear setting become really
relevant here
Etc and so Vitality has a lot to do with
the ability to generate effort with
feeling like at least if not a fast
upward spiral at least a slow upward
spiral and certainly not a slow downward
spiral downwards
right I mean I think you know I'm around
a lot of graduate students and postdocs
and you see how an early success like
publishing a paper early on in one's
career creates an upward spiral around
the whole concept of effort thereafter
you see this in dating and relationships
you see how an early failure can set
people along a downward spiral and so I
think that having Drive
comes from the catecholamines it's
dopamine epinephrine norepinephrine
ensure you need the serotonergic systems
and the endogenous opioid systems that
smooth things out but in the absence of
that get up and go I mean we wouldn't be
here there's no again I wasn't consulted
the design phase but you can be pretty
sure that this is what allows any animal
or human to move toward a milestone